foreign
[Music]
the chestologists good luck we have the
black pieces
against a good player
and let's get the show on the road and
as promised I'm going main meriditski
repertoire
you know by hook or by Crook and we
might be facing a jababa London here
Knight C3 is the introductory move I
will oblige with D5
and this is going to be a very
interesting twist now of course Bishop
F4 is not the only move and we are
indeed facing the jababa London which is
crazy I'm now black against my own
opening but I promise I will not I will
not hold back I will give you my honest
uh recommendations because I don't
believe in false advertising so I'm
going to play what I think is uh the
best system for black
now what you should understand about the
black side of the jababa London is that
it black has five or six there are seven
or eight equalizing lines so it's
impossible to say that E6 for example is
worse than Bishop F5 or A6 is worse than
E6 all of the typical moves for black
here other than Knight C6 uh which
blunders Knight B5 are approximately
equivalent in objective strength this is
very important for people to understand
uh who ask well what is the best what is
the best line against the jababa London
best is a very relative term the lines
are different right and each line leads
to a different type of position and no
matter which line you play with black
you have to know it well because it's
not enough to make a good move here
almost every move is good uh even the
relatively rare C6 uh variation is quite
decent for black But whichever move you
play you have to know the subsequent
Theory quite well and in my opinion the
move that's probably easiest for most
people to understand uh because it's
also the most forcing mode does anybody
know which one I'm implying here what is
the most forcing and one could even call
it the most principled move for black I
think some uh opening articles call this
the most principled response because
you're basically trying to punish white
directly uh for bringing the Knight out
to C3 and I'm talking here about the
direct Central strike C5 what do I mean
when I say you're trying to punish white
for playing Knight C3 well you should
know that in the London system in the
traditional London how is the move C5
oftentimes met well it's often met with
the move c2c3 in order to reinforce the
D4 Pawn so you're trying to highlight
the fact uh that white has brought the
Knight out to C3 and the D4 pawn it has
now become a serious Target and we are
directly assaulting this target with the
move C5 E4 is of course the move in uh
Sasha and my jababa London course so we
are going to follow one of the main
lines of that course
again there are three main moves in this
position all of them are analyzed very
deeply in the course there's C takes D4
there is D takes C4 and there is the
move that I am going to play in this
game which is once again the most
forcing line and it is considered to be
at this point the most reputable
variation uh within C5 and that is to
take on e4 with the knight in order to
force the knights off the board uh
before black white plays D takes C5 so
we play Knight takes C4 white of course
will recapture on e4 that is the only
feasible move uh take note of the fact
that Knight B5 is not dangerous as long
as the Knight remains on B8 this is an
important Point uh because it can always
be met with the defensive move Knight A6
now we trade on e4 white will
re-establish material equality with DC
although in the old days when the jababa
London was first appearing and when this
E4 move came to the fore people were
actually actually playing this Gambit
Style by advancing the pawn to D5 kind
of like a falc beer counter Gambit as
I'll show after the game but it was
quickly determined with the aid of
computers that D5 is unsound uh White
has woefully insufficient compensation
there for the pawn and so people
switched uh to D take C5 again there is
a fork in the road there is of course
Queen takes D1 check which leads to a
fascinating end game it's an equal end
game but it's a very difficult end game
for black to play practically speaking
does anybody know what the second move
is and this is the move that we're gonna
play
does anybody know what the second move
is
yeah he lose on purpose so people buy
the course for sure
uh that's that's what I'm gonna do queen
A5 check very good man
you guys are uh very sharp theoretically
Queen A5 check forking the king and the
C5 Pawn
and we are going down one of the most
topical lines of the course and and of
the jababa London in general we did not
Sasha and I did not invent this line
it's also in Hans demons course on the
jabab it's on it it's in everybody's
course because E4 is the standard
recommendation uh these days by most uh
jababa London authors of course there is
also the old school move which is E3 and
I'll talk a little bit about that move
after the game and I'll explain why I
don't really recommend E3 for jababa
London aficionados okay so Queen takes
C5
and of course we are expecting the move
Queen to A4 check that is precisely why
white blocks the pawn uh the check with
the pawn so that uh the diagonal is open
for the queen and so that white is able
to win back the E4 plot it's interesting
to me that our opponent is taking uh
sizable chunks of time on every move it
tells me that they may be not totally
familiar with the chorus uh or just
trying to remember the theory uh or
realizing that they're playing me
whatever it is
Queen A4 check okay
great
so how do we block this check does
anybody know what the main line is here
do we play Bishop D7 in other words or
do we play Knight C6
so I think newer players might look at
this and say well let's play Bishop D7
because we're attacking the queen
the problem is White's Queen is going to
move anyway on the next move you see
what I'm saying White's next move is
Queen takes E4 of course Queen C6 runs
into Bishop to B5 pinning the queen
so Bishop D7 is a bit of an awkward move
because that Bishop does not belong on
D7 it belongs uh as a later establish on
F5 or on E6 so it makes a lot more sense
to play the more harmonious development
move Knight C6 okay Knight C6 just makes
a lot more sense because White's going
to take on e4 anyway
and now there are a couple of reasonable
moves
the move that I think would tempt uh
most newer players who are not familiar
with this position is Bishop F5 I
definitely think that this is the
natural instinct to bring the bishop out
with Tempo and the reason why Bishop F5
is not the best move is very concrete
and it's not easy to explain in sort of
general terms uh the what I will say is
that in many situations it's a good idea
to keep this bishop on its initial
Square because you don't know whether
later on it belongs on F5 sometimes it
actually belongs on E6 which is a very
easy Square to underestimate uh in these
variations so instead we need to work on
developing our other bishop and you
might say well obviously then we should
play E6 but the problem with E6 is that
it leaves the bishop on C8 in the dust
and the problem with the move E5 here is
that it bites off more than we can chew
the move E5 uh you should understand
intuitively is very very risky because
that Queen 94 is going to pin the pawn
and in general E5 is just a very flimsy
move having not completed our
development and so that leaves us with
one other option and that option is to
play G6 uh in order to deploy the bishop
on the long diagonal Bishop G7 is our
next move
now of course you might look at this and
say well the bishop on G7 is lame right
all of the speedrun I've been talking
about biting on granite and we're
developing the bishop to a square where
it's biting on granite but tactical
considerations always supersede uh
positional
positional reasoning and this is a great
example of that because after the bishop
is deployed to G7 if you're watching on
YouTube you should pause the video at
this point and you should ask yourself
what threat is created after the bishop
is brought to G7 and yes there is a
threat that is created with the move
Bishop G7 and that is as you might
actually know this Hans Neiman famously
blundered this move uh in a Blitz game
and an over the board Blitz game at the
world Blitz championship and quickly
resigned that is the move Bishop takes
C3 check and of course he mixed up the
theory he knew that this was an idea he
simply mixed up the move order in his
mind
now Bishop takes C3 check is a threat
breaking the granite so to speak and BC
Queen takes C3 check picks up the rook
in the corner queen queen takes A1 now
how problematic is that threat to White
well it's problematic enough to where
white has to spend a move in order to
take the sting out of that threat
um and the best way to take the sting
out of it is just to move the stroke out
of the line of fire of the of the black
queen to play Rook to D1 because if
white is already moving The Rook away
then you might as well position it on an
open file less sense would make a move
like Rook C1 because that Rook on C1
would be incredibly passive
but this takes a lot of knowledge
already in order to play this position
accurately white has to have uh reviewed
the course uh and and if you haven't
reviewed the course a lot of people just
default to the move Bishop to E2 and of
course Bishop to E2 that's what Hans
played I'm pretty sure that runs into
Bishop takes E3 with immediate Victory
and again our opponent is taking
long chunks of time but so far that
they've found all of the best moves so
let's see at which point we'll be able
to throw our opponent off
okay so after Rook D1 we're gonna reach
a very interesting Crossroads but never
mind Bishop to D2 and what this move
tells me is that our opponent quickly
diagnosed the threat but did not review
the course did not do their due
diligence and uh was unable to find the
best way to defend C3 our opponent's
move is an example of type 1 prophylaxis
so I divide prophylaxis into two
different sections type 1 prophylaxis is
physically preventing a threat so what
is Black's threat well Black's threat
was Bishop take C3 and queen takes C3
and our opponent's move physically
prevents it this is the most common and
most and the safest type of prophylaxis
because you're literally preventing the
idea from taking hold type 2 prophylaxis
involves taking the sting out of a
particular idea uh again I think it's
important that you realize Bishop F5 is
a good move I think it's a decent move
but I want to maintain mean maximum
flexibility I don't know exactly just
yet where this bishop is going to belong
so let me give you an example let's say
that we Castle which we're gonna do and
let's say that our opponent decides to
play Rook to D1 why might Bishop E6 be a
better development Square in that
particular position well for one thing
it attacks the A2 Pawn right and that
pawn actually can be captured because
the bishop can't be trapped on A2 for
another thing the benefit of bringing
the bishop out to E6 is that it also
restricts the development of its
counterpart on F1 and the third benefit
of the move Bishop E6 uh is that the
bishop can potentially reposition to D5
which I think is a very nice Central
Square and it can pressure the Knight so
don't rush to make Tempo moves just
because their Tempo moves right the
essence of this position is not
contained in developing as quickly as
possible it's contained in developing in
as high quality a manner as possible
so I'm making a big deal out of this
it's not a big deal Bishop F5 is totally
possible I think these moves are
approximately equivalent but I just want
to kind of let you in a little bit on
the logic uh behind my decisions so
Bishop E2 our opponent kind of
developing passively but obviously there
is nothing in particularly wrong with
how our opponent is playing I would say
that black Black's position at this
point might be a little bit preferable
but there's nothing major uh going on
just yet
but let's take a moment here to consider
our candidate moves the two obvious
candidate moves to me are again Bishop
E6 that I have sort of uh advertised as
a possible Improvement to Bishop F5 and
there are still our old friend uh Bishop
F5 but obviously those are not the only
moves looking around the board can we
identify any potential targets that we
might want to uh press on a little bit
well if you think logically the only two
Targets that I see are the queen on e4
which is vulnerable and there is only
one undefended Pawn or peace in White's
entire position and that's the B2 Pawn
so it stems from that it follows from
that that the B2 Pawn can be targeted
and it can be targeted by dropping Our
Queen back to B6 now is this just an
empty one move threat or does this move
actually contain some meaning well I
think it's likelier to be the latter
rather than the former because the Ben
benefit of Queen B6 is that if we can
force the B Pawn to move up well the
benefits of that should be obvious to
you the C3 Pawn is then very seriously
weakened the other benefit of Queen B6
is that white can't play the natural
Rook V1 because then we play Bishop F5
uh skewering the queen and the Rook
so the move Queen B6 oddly enough
actually forces White's Queen I think
back to C2 where it can be subsequently
attacked with Bishop F5 that's one idea
another idea is to switch up the move
order what if we started with Bishop F5
and only after white brought the queen
let's say to C4 did we drop our Queen
back to B6 that's a pretty interesting
idea because at that point white will no
longer be able to drop the queen back to
C2 and white might even have to resort
to a move like Bishop C1 undeveloping
the bishop okay you kind of see where
I'm getting with this another good move
here is to play Rook d8 so because the
position is quite safe for both sides
the price of a move is not that high the
distinction between all of the moves
that I've mentioned is minuscule all of
them are going to have approximately the
same evaluation according to the engine
that would be my guess and so let's not
belabor the point let's make one of
those moves I think it's a good time for
us to play Bishop F5 I think now is as
good a time as any uh to ask this queen
to commit to a different uh place
yeah Bishop F5 I finally decided to play
it
um of course again Bishop E6 was also
quite good even potentially B6 although
I would be very very hesitant to leave
the Knight on C6 without a Defender
and let's see where our opponent ends up
positioning their Queen
the engine once Queen takes C3 LOL
yeah let's forget that ever happened
that was a bad dream
we're also forcing our opponent to make
a decision and that's always a good
thing if you can force your opponent to
make decisions
decisions what did they lead to they
lead to mistakes they lead to regrets
because you start weighing the pros and
cons and suddenly you don't know where
to go so there are I would say two
pressure areas in this position David
says can you talk about pressure errors
that's not really a term pressure areas
but what I think you're asking is where
are we going to apply pressure
subsequently well just looking the over
the board there's only two areas of
pressure that I see right now and that's
one is the B2 Pawn which is why it's
only undefended pawn and the other is
the D file the D file is open once we
put a rook on d8 the bishop on D2 is
potentially going to end up under a good
bit of pressure of course the bishop
could then reposition to E3 etc etc all
of that these subsequent considerations
depend entirely on where white puts the
queen because the situation after Queen
E3 is going to be very different from
the situation if white moves the queen
to the side Queen H4
all good are you sure done
um how do I think about which Rook to
put on d8 I'm not even thinking about
that yet again I'm really not thinking
about anything
uh until my opponent decides where to
put the queen position is equal the
position is equal
um and it's equal in spite of the fact
that white played this slightly weird
move Bishop to D2 because while Bishop
D2 is a little bit awkward it does not
introduce any additional weaknesses to
the position it does not
weaken anything and so it doesn't
seriously change the evaluation as
awkward as this move looks and as
passive as White's development is
passive uh does not equal bet and you
should understand that and now a big
moment for us we need to decide a
whether we're trading queens or not B if
we are trading Queens we have to decide
if we're trading them on E3 or if we're
trading them on one other Square well if
we're trading them on B6 because one of
our candidate moves has to be Queen to
B6 here and the benefits of the queen
trade on B6 should be self-evident too
right by opening up the a file you're
establishing some pressure on the A2
Pawn but so should the drawbacks right
Queen B6 Queen takes B6 a takes B6 that
pod on B6 is going to be a serious
Target and it can be easily targeted by
White's Bishop from E3 so let me think
about this for a couple of moments
to me the queen trade on E3 leads
directly to a very draw shen game these
jababa London end games for my personal
experience tend to be very Josh
so from the perspective of keeping
Intrigue on the board I would like to
keep the Queens on the board having
decided that we now need to decide where
to put the queen do we put it on D5 do
we bring it back to D6 or
and do we play some move like Queen A5
well I don't really see the point in
playing Queen A5 what is the queen doing
on A5 it's also walking into a potential
x-ray me no like
Queen D5 versus queen D6 how do we make
this decision well my intuition on the
one hand is to play Queen D6 because the
queen on D6 is a little bit more out of
the way than it is on D5 but there is a
more concrete consideration which is
that the good thing about putting the
queen on D5 is that it's actually aiming
at the A2 pawn and it's preventing white
from playing or preventing or
discouraging white from playing Rook a
to D1 it's also inducing the weakening
move C4 and we actually want we want
white to play the move C4 we want that
very much because that opens up the
diagonal for our Bishop and it creates
for us a stronghold on D4 that we're
already controlling with two minor
pieces so I like the look of Queen T5 I
think it's a slightly more provocative
move it's a slightly slightly spicier
move than Queen D6 but we're still
talking here about minimal risk our
position is very solid Queen D5 versus
queen D6 still in the category of
relatively unimportant decisions
now what are our next moves likely to be
well I'm expecting white to Castle I'm
expecting white to Castle King side it
seems like the only feasible move to me
although I think newer players might
actually go C4
you know C4 is not out of the question
for a newer player who's looking at this
and gets tempted by the prospect of
attacking the queen
now what are the ways in which we can
improve our position should White Castle
well I think the most obvious move as
I've indicated previously is to bring
the Rook to d8 which Rook do we put on
d8 also doesn't matter essentially I I
will say that I don't have a clear
intuition on which Rook should be put on
d8 if I had to make a choice probably
Rook a to d8 and the reason why it has
to do with what I'm about to say of
course we should also keep an eye on
what's going on in the center you might
assume that the center is wide open but
it's actually not we still have a pawn
in the center that we haven't moved and
we absolutely could consider advancing
this Pawn all the way up to E4 and if we
first put a rook on d8 and then play the
move E5 as you should be able to tell E4
actually becomes a devastating threat
because it kicks the Knight out off of
F3 and potentially White's gonna drop
the bishop on D2
so from that perspective I really like
the look of the move Rook hd8 I think we
should start with that move
I we should see how white responds to it
and then we should make our subsequent
decision let's go Rook 88.
low risk move low stakes move it just
brings The Rook to a better Square
that's all it does
notice that I'm not at this point
thinking about a longer term plan we're
still in the stage of making small
improving moves and kind of seeing how
our opponent positions their pieces
position remains equal this is going to
be hard to win if white plays very
accurately a lot of Subs going on here
okay rubber Tech suggested Knight D4
here but Knight D4 just blunders upon
right we play Knight takes D4 CD and
Bishop takes D4 so that's not uh being
considered
Rook a to D1 again notice why did we put
the queen on D5 in order to Target the
A2 Pawn to try to prevent this Rook from
activating via D1 and the positional
logic here you get well what about Rook
F to do one and that is probably the
best move Rook fd1 I would Hazard a
guess that this is the best move uh but
if white plays Rook fd1 you could then
ask well what about the other Rook the
other rook in that situation is
essentially going to be tied down to the
A1 Square
but still I would play with white the
moo Brooke fd1 and I would do it quite
quickly I would play it without much
thought
and we're gonna have to very slowly very
methodically start to develop more
pressure in the center
we're also thinking about advancing the
pawn up to E5 and controlling more
squares in the center although that move
does come with a small
but not uh insignificant positional
price tag which I'll describe after
White's move I guess I'll take this
opportunity to say as our opponent
Ponders uh his next move that if you're
watching this on YouTube and you're
enjoying the way I describe the moves
and you feel that it helps your chests
subscribing really really helps me put
out more content more frequently we're
trying to reach 500k by the end of the
year it's not a realistic goal I've
brought it down to 400k but every every
sub count so it really this is how I
make my living so thank you to everybody
who puts a like or who subscribes and
helps me fight the clickbait monsters
and of course I stream these speedruns
live on Twitch usually very late at
night so it's kind of hard to catch but
still it's possible if you tune in at
the right moment
H3
okay so our opponent just kind of passes
the turn to us and probably does the
same thing that we were trying to do to
him which is essentially ask okay put
your cards on the table sir so that I
can decide then how to position my
pieces
of course we could do the same thing you
know we could play H6 here
although H6 is an inferior move I think
to H3 because it creates a potential
long-term Target
what do I see when I look at this
position well what I see is that there
is direct pressure on the D2 bishop and
let's not take it
how could that pressure be made manifest
well ideally we would kick this Knight
off of F3 and I've already pointed this
out a very thematic tactical move here
would be to push E5 E5 also controls key
squares in the center so I really like
the look of the move E5 it finally
introduces a small element of tactics
into an otherwise very insipid position
should we prepare E5 with Rook fte8 I
don't think so I don't see the need to
do that because after we play E5 that
pawn is already sufficiently well
defended by our minor pieces and our
Queen so weighing the pros and cons of
E5 what are the cons of this move well
for one thing when you push upon it
creates weaknesses in its wake right so
we're making small weaknesses on the
king side right the dark squares but
those squares are unexploitable white is
not in a position to exploit any of the
weak squares that are created with the
movie 5. if you see what I'm saying
let's go for it let's go for it let's
try to put some pressure and let's
control some key Central squares E5 on
the board
I'm still in uh commentary mode a little
bit I think
for those watching on YouTube earlier
today the day of recording I'm I was
compensating the Magna secaro SCC final
if you haven't seen that you should
check it out uh in the archive of the
chess.com YouTube channel in fact you
should rather be watching you should
probably be watching that rather than
the speedrun video If you haven't seen
it already
well we have a threat we finally have a
threat we have a threat of pushing E4
presumably our opponent is going to
start accelerating the pace of his play
and Rook fd1 is an excellent move why is
it an excellent move well because it
reinforces the bishop and it presumably
takes the sting out of the move E4
E4 still needs to be considered but the
purpose of that move is no longer to win
the bishop on D2 because that Bishop is
now protected if we were to play E4 it
would have to be played for different
reasons than we would play it here
I'm actually not such a huge fan of this
move because well it kicks the night
away but the Knight has plenty of
retreating squares it can go back to E1
it can go to the side and when we play
the move E4 we might potentially bite
off more than we can chew in the center
right we're also weakening the D4 Square
so it's a committal move it's an
interesting move let's consider our
other candidates and if we don't find
anything that we like I think we'll
Resort back to E4
so a lot of you are spotting this move
Bishop C2 but the issue is after Bishop
C2 white plays Rook D to C1 and we could
probably make a draw we could play
Bishop F5 and I don't think white has
anything better there than to repeat
moves with Rook T1 but we don't want to
draw we obviously want to play for a win
so after Bishop C2 Rook C1
could we play Bishop E4 no that drops a
minor piece to C4 Bishop C2 could be met
with Bishop D3 now it could be followed
up with Bishop D3 but that just leads to
a bunch of Trades and I'm not enthralled
by our prospects in that end game
okay
so let's come back to E4 for a second
what actually happens if we play E4 so
the benefit of the move E4 is that it
creates for our Knight a stronghold on
what Square when we play the move E4
what Outpost deep in White's territory
is created for our Knight a little bit
of practice positional practice
yeah the D3 square right so the D3
square is a very tender Square in
general and when we put a Pawn on e4 we
carve out for our Knight a potential
Pathway to D3
we should keep in mind that just like
we're aiming at the A2 Pawn white is
aiming at the A7 Pawn
uh so we should keep that pawn protected
but if we play E4 and then maybe throw
in a move like B6 we will be ready to
get our Knight to uh D3 so the more I
like I look at this move the more I like
it uh let's spice things up with E4
let's spice things up with E4 is this a
move that I would play in a classical
game
maybe not right but in the context of a
Speed Run game I think this gives us a
little bit more uh to chew on in this
position
and if our opponent refute said okay
congrats
no so Knight G5 here would be a very
serious mistake who can tell me why why
would Knight G5 be a serious mistake H6
yeah H6 simply traps the Knight why does
it trap the Knight because Knight takes
E4 there's just Queen takes E4 that E4
Pawn is guarded by two different pieces
so after Knight G5 H6 white can try the
move C4 counter-attacking the queen and
trying to make us lose contact with the
E4 Pawn but after Knight G5 H6 C4 the
clinical move there is to slide the
queen up to D4 right any time a pawn is
pushed first thing that you should think
about what squares are left behind so
when you reason in that way after the
move C4 is played you should immediately
notice the D4 square is now an
accessible parking spot for our Queen we
play Queen D4 and we win the game Bishop
E1 Bishop E1 counter-attacking Our Queen
I saw this move
I saw this move I thought that we could
just slide Our Queen over to A5
but maybe I underestimated that move we
could also play the move Queen back to
E6
but then there's Knight H4 probably E4
was a mistake probably E4 was a was a
positional mistake but we'll see we'll
see yeah I think we should play Queen A5
no Queen E5 learner's the queen we
should play Queen A5
kind of scandy style right where we play
Queen D5 Queen A5
and now we're gonna get a little bit of
a spicy position
is it awkward well awkward yeah it's a
little bit awkward it's a pretty weird
Square for the queen but it's you know
we could drop it back to B6 we could
bring it back to the center I'm not
terrified of our Queen permanently being
out of the game or anything like that
it's the I think it's the only move
Queen A5
again notice that I'm constantly trying
to pose dilemmas for my opponent now our
opponent has to decide where to move
this Knight
all right Knight D2 Knight H4 even
Knight D4 is now a move
um and dilemmas waste time and at this
level I'm always keeping an eye on the
clock always and the more decisions that
you force your opponent to make the more
time you're gonna bleed off their clock
this is what Hikaru does that that's so
effective he's constantly forcing you to
make difficult decisions and you just
can't make them fast because you need to
weigh all of your options
well I really add drag Nails how do you
know where to move your pieces when
they're a tactile first of all I don't
but there was a specific reason that I
didn't play Queen E6 and I'll explain it
after the game and the specific reason
uh is the move Knight H4 now you might
be looking at this that move and saying
why is Knight H4 dangerous I'll explain
afterward
but what you should realize is that here
I'm allowing the bishop to potentially
drop back to E6
Knight D4 okay
well that doesn't give us much of a
choice I mean I think Bishop takes D4 is
out of the question why would we
voluntarily give up our fiancado Bishop
and create massive holes on the king
side
not taking on D4 to me is also more or
less out of the question because well
white wants to take on F5 and
potentially even take on C6 so I really
don't see the reason that we would
decline the trade let's go Knight 64.
white is going to recapture with the
pawn I assume I don't know what our
opponent is thinking about but I hope
it's something productive
yeah CD
okay and now we need to decide once
again where we position Our Queen
ow
D4 is a Target and it should be
self-evident to you that this is an
isolated pawn and because it's an
isolated pawn it should be the Target
that we focus on now there are two main
ways that we can attack that pawn maybe
even three we can drop it back to B6 but
concretely white will bring the bishop
up to C3 and you should see that you
should see that after Queen B6 white has
Bishop C3 and maybe B6 is not the best
score for the queen there is also the
square D5 and queen D5 contains the
benefit of blockading that pawn so it
prevents white in the future from
pushing D5 on the other hand
on the other hand Queen D5 steals the
Thunder From The Rook and if we come
back for a second to the queen B6
variation one of the benefits of going
Queen B6 is that after Bishop C3 we can
increase the pressure on the D4 Pawn by
doubling Rooks we could go Rook D7 and
rook fd8 and all of our pieces now are
contributing to the attack on D4 whereas
if we play Queen D5 after Bishop C3
we're at a bit of a dead end when it
comes to attacking the D4 Pawn so my
logic is as follows I think that we
should drop the queen back to B6 where
it's out of the way of the Rooks of
course a byproduct of this move is that
we're pressuring the B2 Pawn but that's
not very significant if white plays
Bishop C3
definitely this looks like the best
Square to me now we should refrain from
the move Rook to D5 I think some of you
might be thinking well if we're already
doubling on the D file why don't we also
blockade the pawn well because Rook D5
walks right into Bishop C4 Rook D6 I
think is just generally awkward uh
because it puts the Rooks on alignment
and we should try to avoid that one
possible
on the other hand you could argue that
white can't really exploit that
alignment and on the next move you're
going to go Rook fd8 anyway so what are
we worried about yeah that's a
reasonable argument but I don't see any
good reason to refrain from uh Rook D7 I
just don't
maybe in some situations actually Rook
D6 might be better but this is like
minuscule detail and I think we should
just go for it now I know that a lot of
you are thinking what about G4 did you
blunder G4 I did not blunder G4
I want white to play G4 and that's
actually part of the reason I played
Rook D7 I'm trying to provoke our
opponent into pushing G4 and G4 forces
us to drop our Bishop back to E6 so no
it's not some tactics that I spotted yes
we're gonna sacrifice the E4 Pawn but I
looked at the position that occurs
afterward and I believe that Black's
compensation is not only very nice
objectively but also overwhelming
practically and I think it's not a
surprise that our opponent is shying
away from that let's double Rooks on the
D file our opponent does the same and
then we need to decide on our subsequent
strategy for pressuring our opponent
yeah it's terrible positionally it's
terrible tactically G4 is the least the
least of my concerns here
now what do I see at this point when I
look at the position well we have
pressured the D4 upon with everything
that we've got we need to determine
where else on the board we can apply
pressure and kind of looking around one
interesting observation that we can make
is that well the queen and the Rook are
aligned right so if we could get our
Bishop to H6 well that would be a big
deal because the queen is also almost
out of squares there is a classical
method for preparing Bishop H6 in almost
every position where your castled king
side that is to start with H5 which I
should add is a pretty productive move
in itself right as a standalone move
this is a good move because it it
improves the pawn structure uh looking
forward to an end game and of course It
prepares King H7 and Bishop H6 we're
using our King to prepare The Bishop's
maneuver to H6
it's a classy move it's it's a motif
that you should be familiar with because
it is incredibly common across many
different types of positions Bishop C4
okay so is our opponent preparing to go
D5 I don't think so D5
doesn't seem very scary to me and I
think that we can safely continue with
our idea especially because King H7
unpins the F Pawn and notice that by
putting the Rook on D7 I didn't
anticipate this of course
but it's kind of nice that The Rook is
also guarding F7
so I think we've retroactively our
decision to play Rook D7 rather than
Rook D6 has been Justified
oh this is definitely going to be a
close game I I mean I'm I've been
floored by the level displayed by our
opponents in the speedrun
and none of the games the last 20 games
have has even been remotely easy the
margins have been very thin and I'm
playing to the best of my ability
so does everybody understand why Bishop
H6 is a threat you might look at this
and say well what about F4 blocking the
diagonal of course we have e takes F3 on
Passat important tactical detail Bishop
H6 is a threat because it's skewers the
queen and the Rook and suddenly another
dilemma for our opponent because
remember D4 is the main weakness so you
could say well why can't white just move
the queen well where is White going to
move it right if white moves it to G3
then white already has to calculate
Bishop takes D4 and that's a lot of
calculation because the situation
sharpens up there could potentially be
five or six captures on D4 maybe white
can take on F7 at the end of the line
let's let our opponent calculate this
line let's let our opponent calculate
this line we're going to cross that
bridge if we get there there's no need
to calculate that yet at all because
white might just as well play the move
D5 here which leads us to a completely
different type of position
if there's no use calculating long lines
before y makes the decision
yeah D5 force is a queen trade yes it
does it does
but we're not necessarily opposed to a
queen trade yeah time the time situation
getting a little bit dire for white I'm
going to keep that in mind as I make my
subsequent decisions
thank you space jaguar and Rook C2
so our opponent makes a very reasonable
response he moves The Rook away from the
D2 Square
now there's a lot that I see here the
first is that we can play Bishop takes
D4 let's calculate Bishop D4 Bishop D4
Rook D4
let's say Rook D4 and unfortunately
white is able to pick up at the end of
the line the F7 Pawn now the line
doesn't end there after Bishop takes F7
who can tell me a reasonable looking
move a move that you have to at least
consider because it looks quite scary
for white yeah it's Rook T1 check
the king is forced to move to H2 now in
our pocket as the move Queen takes E3
and that's an equal end game but apart
from Queen takes E3 we can also slide
Our Queen over to D6 with check and one
observation that we should make right
now is that Rook C2 moves The Rook onto
an x-ray if we can dislodge the queen
from E3 we do have the potential for E3
that leads us to another candidate move
and that is the move Bishop H6 the
problem with Bishop H6 is that once the
queen moves away let's say it's E2 and
we play the move E3 white could block
that with his Bishop Bishop back to D3
and I'm not seeing a clear follow-up in
that position so from that perspective I
like the move Bishop takes D4 and I just
saw something very promising I just saw
something very promising I don't know if
it leads to Victory or what but I think
we should
give this move a shot I think we should
give this move a shot because we've made
all of the improvements that we can make
this move stems quite naturally from the
way that we've played whether or not
something exists we'll try to figure
that out when the when the critical
position is reached okay
so our opponent is gonna take the Rook
I'm positive of that and we at least
need to consider Queen takes D4
so Queen takes D4 is a very tricky move
because if white plays Bishop F7 he
drops The Rook to a fork
and after Rook D4 Queen D4 Queen D4 Rook
D4 Bishop F7 suddenly the X-ray against
whites Rook has opened up and the move
E3 has become possible
unfortunately after E3 white could just
slide The Rook over to E2 and I'm not
seeing a clear and convincing follow-up
in that position
and have to think about it and he
doesn't do it our opponent panics
our opponent panics and he declines to
to re-establish material equality
that gives us an obvious Edge
okay
but obviously the game continues we're
only up a pawn
now the move that's that's that's
begging to be played here of course is
Rook D1 check I think we should play
this move right now and think later
because this move clarifies the
situation quite a bit it forces at the
very least it gives us the possibility
of a bunch of Trades
now if white plays King H2 here to keep
the tension we wouldn't have had to
trade anything if we didn't want to but
that's a moot point because now we do
have to trade uh at least a pair of
Rooks and there's going to be a big
decision uh that we're going to have to
make after King H2 we're gonna have to
make a big decision after King H2 do we
trade Queens on E3
do we slide Our Queen over to D6 and try
to keep the Queens on the board or do we
make some third move
uh do we try to keep the tension in some
way I don't know we'll have to decide
do we give a check on C7 well Queen C7
check to me doesn't make as much sense
because it walks the queen right into
the Rooks x-ray you know why would we
create further preconditions for some
sort of a freak combination you know
what I'm saying although on the other
hand you could say well after Queen C7
white doesn't really have any
discoveries other than Bishop B3 which
is just a one move threat so there's a
discussion to be had there but we don't
have much time I like the look of Queen
D6 check because it provokes a weakness
with G3 and if after Queen D6 white
plays Queen G3 we can Resort back to our
E3 at motif
so I kind of like the look of Queen D6
check here intuitively and given our
time constraints we're gonna go for it
Queen D6 check again we're forcing our
opponent to make a decision Queen G3 our
decision
a decision was made quickly
okay so E3 Queen D6 Rook D6 rookie two
what's going on there Rook D2 is a move
well we could essentially go into that
pawn up end game and try to convert it
not the worst idea in the world
can we play for checkmate here can we
get our Queen to G1 somehow
we could think about it right we could
play Queen F6 and keep the Queens on the
board
that doesn't seem half bad either Queen
F6 what about that keeping the Queens on
the board maybe setting up the threat of
H4 okay it's largely a matter of taste I
think what we end up doing here
um a Soviet Schoolboy type player
uh would probably
would probably want to trade Queen zero
play E3
a you know more combative player might
want to go Queen F6 to keep the Queens
on the board I'm inclined to not trade
especially given the fact that I
consider myself good at time scrambles
and this is just a more exciting move
but where do we put our Queen we can
also drop it back to D7 so it's not a
given the queen F6 is the best Square
Queen E7 is also possible
Queen E7 is also possible but
intuitively I like Queen F6 intuitively
I like Queen F6 because it also aims at
the B2 pawn and it also sets up the idea
of H4 okay
and why do I keep indicating this move
H4 because if we can force whites Queen
off of the h2b8 diagonal we can return
to that diagonal potentially with
devastating effect okay so our opponent
is allowing E3
he's also allowing H4 there's also Rook
D3 I need to start thinking quite
seriously here I'm liking the look of H4
I'll be honest
it feels like there should be something
there
E3 rookie 2 is less convincing that it
may appear to some people let's start
with the move H4 let's start with H4 and
then we'll see let's start with H4 and
then we'll see I like this move I think
it's a low risk move
I think it's very important for
everybody to understand what our
response is going to be to Queen C7
and I think we need to educate our
opponent as well and I need to educate
myself
on what our response is going to be
is it E3 rookie two
I want to go Rook D7 that's the basic
idea I want to go Rook D7 we're going to
do it now
unfortunately that means moving The Rook
away from the eighth uh the first rank
on the other hand it ensures the safety
of our king queen C5 that's a great move
okay could play V6 keep attacking could
play Queen G5
okay B6 just to make sure that A7 is
protected that pawn was hanging that
pawn was hanging we're also constantly
trying to dislodge the queen so that it
loses contact with the E5 square and it
does lose contact with that square and
we're starting to make serious strides
here Queen E5 check I think is very
strong because it forces G3
it forces G3 because if the king moves
back then we Checkmate white on the
first rank now we need to consider Rook
D3
and Rook D3 stems very naturally from
the way that this game has progressed I
like Rook D3 because it hits the queen
and it x-rays the G3 pawn and notice if
white goes Queen F4 right now that loses
the game because we could take the queen
and take the pawn on H3 which is now
Under Fire
so we're starting to Bow a constrict
White's position here bit by bit bit by
painful bit Queen G5 is what I would
play with white Queen G5 is an All-Star
move and I'm trying to figure out our
response to Queen G5 I think we're just
gonna take and make a slow move like
King she said Queen F4 okay Queen F4
takes takes takes takes takes their
still not over actually because why does
infiltrating D7
ah takes an E3
aha wait I have an idea
takes takes takes an E3 I think might
win the game let me think
so I actually am going to take on F4 I'm
not gonna take on G3 and now we're gonna
play E3
and probably that was a blunder but I
don't know I don't care
now here's the general logic what am I
seeing when I play this move well what
I'm seeing first and foremost what is
our response to Fe who can tell me what
is our response to F takes E3 this is
the main this is the Zen of our strategy
what is our response to F takes E3 it's
Rook takes B3 suddenly the bishop is
under Fire
this was the whole point
um the bishop is under Fire the pod on
F2 is under Fire the move that was
worrying to me initially was rookie two
but then we can Resort back to our old
idea and play e takes F2 Rook takes F2
and Rook takes H3 check and at that
point we'll be up two Pawns in the end
game that should be a pretty much
straightforwardly technically winning
position okay now I think we have a
brilliant move and when I say brilliant
I don't mean brilliant tactically I mean
conceptually very strong what should we
do here
should we play e takes F2 and Rook takes
H3 check no
should we play Rook D2 no because white
can take and play Bishop B3
instead we should go back to D7
and this is what I had to see
when I was playing the move E3
Rogue D2 would be a very instructive
mistake because white could take on D2
and suddenly drop the bishop back to B3
and I'm not even sure that black is
winning there probably black is winning
but it's very convoluted
Rook D7 though wins the game because
white cannot defend the bishop the pawn
and white even has to worry about e
takes F2 the game is over
Bishop takes G6 okay that's technically
the best move I guess
what should we take with what should we
take with
well we should take with a bishop
because King takes G6 would have run
into Rook C6 check notice that I'm being
precise to the end right no reason to
give your opponent any additional
resources now we simplify and now we
identify the target the easiest way to
win up a piece like this is to identify
the most attackable Target and then to
go after it the most attackable Target
here is obviously the H3 Pawn what's the
ideal Arrangement well it's to put the
bishop on F5 and then to basically
pre-move Rook to D3
that is going to pick off the h-bawn and
then we're going to convert by
ultimately pushing that extra Pawn the
other rule even in time scrambles is
that you don't need to hurry what's the
drawback of Rook D3 well why are we
allowing why are we allowing a check on
G on E7 let's bring our King up first
let's bring our King up first
in order to take the sting out of rookie
seven then Rook D3 is gonna be even more
powerful okay so these minor points are
so important when you're converting
because they essentially are the points
that guarantee Victory check on G2
we can sidestep to F6 it doesn't really
matter at this point and now Rook takes
H3 is going to happen
we can also keep an eye out for the
possibility of Rook trades if we could
trade Rooks that might ease our task
even further
and uh it's over I think white might
resign here wow this was uh this is a
really interesting game actually really
interesting game
okay Rook H3
now the easiest way of winning this game
because you might look at this and say
well okay let's move our Rook away from
H3 and then push H3 but the white king
is going to park itself on H2 so a rook
and our Bishop alone are not really
going to be able to uh to supersede
White's blockade so it's always a good
idea in such situations to find a way to
involve your king it's an all hands on
deck effort the other good practice is
to tie down your opponent's pieces so
from which Square could we Tie Down The
Rook well obviously from the B3 Square
you should be keenly aware of the power
of such a move because you're keeping
the white Rook tied down to the second
rank now we can't move it can only move
laterally and now we can just get the
king to F5 well to get the king to F5 we
need to move the bishop where should we
move the bishop we can move it to E4 or
G4 the bishop E4 check is a Tempo move
so uh why not you know
notice that I'm not hurrying with H3 I'm
not hurrying with H3 there's no rush the
pawn is perfectly
uh chilling on H4
and when we're ready we're gonna play H3
now here the easiest is now to
infiltrate with our King to G4 and the
moment you involve your king in the
process the win becomes so much easier
this is what you're gonna find
immediately there is a Checkmate in two
moves Rook H3 Rook H1 is mate and that
ends the game 50 moves
what a difficult win geez okay GG to the
chastologist and I really really
appreciate our opponent allowing us to
replay the game after that Mouse slip
great game
and a lot to talk about
so what I will not do is give you a 45
minute overview of the jababa London I
will say for those watching on YouTube I
have a jabal London course that I
released a couple months ago with Sasha
Bortnick my great friend and a very
strong GM
uh that course is a comprehensive
overview of all variations stemming from
this position but I will not be cheap I
will give you as much as I can in this
speedrun game but I will just point you
to that course if you're interested in
learning more about how to play the
jibaba from White's perspective
from Black's perspective as I pointed
out at the start
as I pointed out at the start and I
guess my editor will splice together
these two games C5 is the most topical
uh line because it is also the most
forcing variation in the old days when
this position was first reached right
when people started playing the jabal
London around 20 2014 2015 E4 was
unheard of it was not a move at all
the first person to play this move E4
was uh Alexander bakulin 2009 Nils
grendelius was actually one of the first
people to play this move Sasha Bortnick
played it and Sasha was the fifth person
to play E4 so he is responsible for a
lot of the development of ideas in this
variation
so what were people doing before well of
course before people were going E3 and
E3 is very much a playable move but the
system that uh caused me to not
recommend this is this very annoying
move Bishop to G4 and I'm not gonna
delve too deeply into the particulars of
this line I will only say that uh the
appeal of playing E3 is that a lot of
newer players just automatically play
Knight C6 and as you know by now it runs
into Knight B5 and there is no good way
to defend the C7 Square no good way to
defend that square uh you already know
like the concept that after E5 white
should play Bishop takes E5
uh etc etc white wins at least upon
but if black knows what to do and plays
Bishop to G4 or even plays the main move
which is A6 white has no advantage that
there is just no advantage in this
position it looks like an exchange Caro
with a bad Knight on C3 and that's
basically what it is
okay
uh so E4 adds a lot of spice to this
variation and once again I will point
you to the course if you want more
information on Black's other moves in
this position C takes D4 Queen takes D4
Knight C6 for example you respond with
Bishop B5 this line is very interesting
D takes C4 D takes C5 is in my opinion
the least appealing of the three options
available to Black of the three captures
I think D takes C4 practically speaking
is the worst of them uh the position
here is very very difficult for black
um and black could lose this in the span
of five moves so for instance
um I'm gonna give you an example
why is this line so dangerous for black
all right
so after uh D takes E4 D takes C5
by far the most popular move here is to
play with Queen takes D1 Chuck and after
Rook takes C1 black is already at risk
of losing this game so for example
totally natural move Knight C6 after
Knight B5 you can essentially resign
you can essentially resign because
Knight C7 is totally Unstoppable most
people here play A6 who can tell me what
the drawback of the move A6 is and what
is a very thematic positional move that
exploits that drawback if you're
watching on YouTube great chance to
pause the video and practice your
positional understanding
no it's just that this is a new computer
that's why I didn't I didn't have the
course
so classic way of thinking what Square
does it weaken it weakens the B6 Square
what piece do we want on B6 well
obviously the Knight so the move Knight
A4 should be very natural to you now of
course black will say Over My Dead Body
and play Knight bd7 but the move Knight
bd7 blocks the natural development of
the bishop we can now support the C5
Pawn with B4 and Black's position is
extremely difficult to play for example
if black now plays the move E5 which is
very natural we drop our Bishop back to
D2 if black plays the move A5 we ask
ourselves the same question what Square
does this move weaken and well clearly
the B5 square and we immediately stick a
bishop onto that square
a takes B4 Bishop takes B4 and black is
completely paralyzed black is losing
Bishop B7 Knight B6
hitting the bishop hitting the rook and
after Knight E2 black is literally out
of moves it's sug the best move
according to the engine is to Castle and
give up the D7 piece so this is how
yucky these end games get for black and
how quickly they can get bad
and it's not like we were playing in
such a Cooperative manner black was
making natural moves so in this position
better is to play Queen A5
but now we sacrifice the C5 Pawn for
Rapid development does anybody know what
White's best move is in this position
does anybody know
what should white do here
so first of all you should not defend
the C5 Pawn you should not try to defend
the C5 Pawn that's not the point the
point is a rapid development of your
pieces
rapid development of your pieces
so it's not Bishop B5 although that's a
good try
yeah vinvin got it it's Queen to D2 what
is the idea to quickly castle queenside
and to threaten Checkmate on d8
um Knight C6 loses on the spot to Knight
B5
a lot of GMS have lost like this by the
way Knight C7 is Unstoppable
uh so white black has to play this very
awkward move Bishop D7 and now we get
our Knight across the G3 in order to
pick up the E4 Pawn black is in huge
trouble Knight C6 bang knight takes C4
deflection
very very difficult position for black
to play so that is the reason why I
don't like d take C4 and why Knight
takes C4 is by far by far the safest
option so 94 d e d take C5 so here again
there's another Crossroads in the course
we analyze this end game very very
deeply this end game is equal but like
the other one it's very difficult for
black to play this properly and if black
plays a bunch of natural moves then very
often black gets into serious trouble in
this line quite quickly our main line
goes Knight C6 now Bishop E3 E5 and
there's this very interesting move that
Bortnick and I discovered F3 in order to
break apart uh the pawn on e4 and to
facilitate the active development of our
minor pieces yeah we undouble Black's
pawns but on the other hand we get a
very nice developing Square for our
Knight and then we can connect our C
Pawn by going C3 and B4 very thematic
idea anyways you can check the course
for more info Queen A5 check is the main
move C3 takes Queen A4 this is all very
standard Fair G6 Knight F3 and Bishop G
sub and here our opponent makes an
inaccuracy Bishop D2 is definitely not
the topical move the topical move is
Rook to D1 and this once again leads to
some very interesting complications
uh of course as I indicated uh you do
not want to go Bishop E2 do not forget
to defend against the threat of Bishop
takes you through or you will lose in 11
moves so you have to take the sting out
of Bishop takes C3 and you do it by
moving The Rook away from the line of
fire of Black's Queen this is Type 2
prophylaxis
after black castles the move here is
Bishop to E3 hitting the queen and the
main line in our course is Queen A5 the
other Bishop comes out to C4 and the
queen can potentially slide over to H4
creating the typical threats of Knight
G5 and Bishop H6 with the potential for
a strong King side attack and we're
already on move 14 and basically the
course is only beginning here
so Rogue D1 is I think the only
challenging move Bishop D2 is okay but
clearly this is not the kind of move
that is going to seriously challenge
black from a theoretical standpoint okay
so Bishop D2 castles and Bishop to E2
and here we decided to develop the
bishop to F5 which I think is a very
reasonable Choice Bishop F5
uh Queen to E3
and we decided on the Move Queen to D5
again I think this was a very reasonable
choice I would not spend too long here
trying to discern the tiny differences
between the various retreating moves I
think that Queen D5 is as reasonable of
a move as the other alternative so
castles
and Rook a to d8 Rook after D1 I think
would have been by far the most natural
move I think H3 is a waste of a Tempo
that allowed us to send this epon up the
board the benefit of playing Rook fd1
is that if we now play E5 here white is
in time to drop the bishop back to E1
and completely prevent the possibility
of E4
so after Bishop E1 let's say that we
bring the queen back to A5 as we did in
the game
who can tell me a nice retreating move
that not only prevents E4 but also
controls some key light squares in the
center
what's like a it's one of those cager
retreating moves yeah Knight D2 Knight
D2 is a nice move to bear in mind
uh because E4 is now controlled by the
white knight uh C4 can be used as a
Transit point for whitesnite especially
because it hits the queen and it's not
so easy for black to improve their
position if you play Rook fe8 I would
actually get the Knight over to E4 now
we're threatening Knight D6 you know and
black has to bring the queen back and
now white could buttress the Knight with
F3 I think this is a completely tenable
position for white it's approximately
equal it's approximately equal
so I would not have wasted time on the
Move H3 it's not a big deal but it's a
small inaccuracy and I think after E5
we're able to add a little bit of spice
to this position
so I didn't really understand this move
from White's perspective E5 and now Rook
fd1 good move good move I think it's the
only reasonable move and interestingly
according to the con
according to the computer Queen A5 or
actually E4 excuse me
so E4 is very interesting this is the
third best move and the evaluation here
is equal according to the engine
according to stockfish the only way to
keep an advantage pat on the back if you
saw this idea Bishop C2 Rook C1 and what
do you think the computer recommends
here for black what do you think the
computer recommends here for black and
it's the only reasonable move now that
you've gone Bishop C2
yeah Bishop D3 orchestrating what
orchestrating a bunch of traits now why
did I reject this move because I figured
my logic went like as follows I saw this
position in my mind and as sexy as it
looks to have a rook on D3 white has
this simple move Bishop E3 and I wasn't
really able to evaluate this position I
thought that there's a very high
probability that everything gets
exchanged along the D file I thought
that White's gonna go King F1 King E2
and then play Rook D1 and once all of
the Rooks are exchanged I'm not really
seeing the winning chances for black
what does the computer give after Bishop
E3 the computer gives Rook F to d8 which
is reasonable now King F1
and now the engine gives the move F5
and if white blindly follows his
strategy with King E2 black wins with F4
ah and if Bishop D2 then suddenly E4 and
look at how quickly Black's pawns run
through White's pieces you have to go
Bishop C5 here
now Rook 3 to D5
forcing the bishop back to A3
and again in comes the e-pawn E4 forcing
the Knight back allowing The Rook to
infiltrate and it should be very clear
to you that white is suffering here
Bishop F6 Bishop H4 is a very nice
maneuver and black is winning plus four
so it's amazing how quickly the computer
is able to generate pressure and how
easy it is to stop calculating here and
start telling yourself a story right the
story that you tell your ah King E2 Rook
D1 and it's going to be a draw
that was a lazy evaluation I should have
seen F5 now does F5 win the game no but
white is already in trouble white has to
go 91
and now the Rook drops back and black is
a very very nice Pawn majority in the
king side
and if white goes King E2 here again
there is this F4 idea
and you might say well what if white
plays G3 what if white prevents F4 and
G3 actually is a good move
the computer gives Bishop F6 look how
stubborn look how stubborn the engine is
Bishop F6
and if King E2
then G5
and if you play Rook D1 right now
finally White's been able to get the
Rook to D1 F4 black just continues as
though nothing's happening and if Bishop
C5 there is a very instructive move that
black has in this position who can tell
me how black should resolve the tension
on the D file what should black do here
this is tremendously instructive
now it's not F3 I think some of you
might be uh attracted to this idea but
there's remember there's a knight on E1
and it's guarding F3 you can't deflect
the king
so you don't trade you play this
collinear move Rook to D5 remember that
a collinear move is a move that is
played along the same file when two
pieces are staring at each other so
moves like Rook D5 I mean Rook D2 would
be a collinear move these types of moves
are very very easy to miss from a
distance
and I have the perfect example of a
collinear move let me see if I can dig
it up I have it on Alicia study
have it on Alicia study I think this
will very nicely illustrate how powerful
these types of moves can be how hard
they can be to figure out
how hard they can be to figure out and I
know who was playing Black so
this is the starting position
okay this is the starting position all
right so what's going on here well let's
start by figuring out a relatively
simple tactic that white has at his
disposal it's white to play can anybody
find a red this is a thematic relatively
vanilla type of idea
what what does white have here
what does white have here yeah Knight
takes C6 right quite easy to find
because the Rook on d8 is unprotected
okay and so black can't play BC because
of Queen takes d8 easy
so black has to play Rook takes D3 and
white plays Knight takes A5 and now we
have a situation where the Rooks are
staring at each other so what's the
automatic move here for black well the
automatic move is obviously Rook takes
D1 white plays Rook takes D1 and
unfortunately black does not have the
time to Fork the knights with Bishop to
B4 why well because white has this check
on d8 it's not mate but it forces the
bishop back to f8
similarly you don't have the opportunity
to bring this bishop out to D7
so in this position there is an
incredible move
that gives black a big advantage and
it's an incredibly hard move to find
unless you know what you're looking for
by the way I should also point out that
this Rook is hanging but if you take it
white takes D3 and once again black just
doesn't have anything going for him
you guys are very close
it's Rook to D7 it's Rook D3 back to D7
the collinear move now what makes this
move so special well let's break this
move down first of all it puts the Rook
on a defended Square
what happens if white simply takes on D7
well black takes back with the bishop
and what has black achieved as a result
of the last two moves black has brought
the bishop out why is that important
well the line continues The Rook is
hanging it has to move to D1 and the
bishop drops back to E8 and black has
achieved an ideal setup the Knight on A5
is now officially trapped and it's
trapped two different ways we're
threatening B6 and we're threatening the
fork with Bishop to B4 there is nothing
that white can do about this white can
prevent one of the threats but not the
other
B6 cannot be prevented at all
um so the winning move is Rook D3 back
to D7 a very awkward looking move but
once you understand the principle behind
it it starts to become a lot clearer I
think you don't want to give the D file
away you want to ensure that the light
squared Bishop is developed and a
collinear move helps you do that much
simpler example one second much simpler
example of a collinear move collinear
moves can be positional they can be
positional collinear moves can also
fight for control over certain important
squares they can be vehicles through
which you essentially gain control of
the position in some uh in some
abstract-ish way
but for instance this position
there's another easy illustration
this is from the game of John Nunn who's
a grand master white to play what would
you do here white to play how does white
increase his Advantage well better why
is white better because white has more
space and in general the better pieces
what do you think John Nunn did here
very strong move
excellent the Bishops are staring at
each other Bishop B3 to C5 collinear
move what's so great about this move
well so what's so great about it is you
say listen I'm happy to trade Bishops
but if you want to trade Bishops you're
gonna have to help me improve the
placement of my queen and the Queen on
C5 is now a beast
and if black doesn't do anything white
can follow up with this move Knight A4
or even solidify the bishop with B4
okay so Bishop C5 positional move
collinear moves can be tactical but that
is the concept in a nutshell
okay back we go to our speedrun game
so bit rug D5 is a collinear move that
is positional because we do not want to
give up control over the D file and we
also want to Garner a Tempo what can we
use this Tempo to do well after Bishop
A3 we can use this Tempo to advance the
pawn to E4 but for example and White's
position is very unpleasant because Rook
takes d500 T1 now runs into the move F3
check and we maintain control in this
way over the D file uh continuing to
pose white with serious difficulties and
so that was the top engine move it was
this bishop C2 Bishop D3 maneuver to get
into the end game but instead I decided
to keep the Queens on the board
and instead we decided on the very
committal move E4 now the question that
almost all of you guys were asking were
wondering
is why after our opponent's response
Bishop B1 did we not drop the queen back
to E6 who can actually tell me the
reason who was paying attention as I was
explaining this what is the reason that
Queen E6 which seems like a less awkward
move it keeps the kick Queen in the
center what was the problem with this
move
well the problem with this move and you
should see this immediately is that the
bishop on F5 is left out of breath and
after Knight H4
there are two problems the first and the
biggest one is that G4 is now a big
threat now we can prevent G4 right we
can play the move H5 in fact we should
play H5 but the second problem is that I
didn't want to give away the bishop pair
I didn't want to allow white to
eliminate our light squared bishop and
you might say well I don't understand
after we play E4 isn't the bishop bad
anyway like why don't we want to give it
away well the reason isn't because the
bishop is so good it's because it's
guarding the E4 pawn and my worry was
that in the long run this E4 Pawn is
going to now be a serious weakness and I
don't want the queen to just have to
babysit that pawn forever I want a
different piece to babysit that pawn so
that the Quinn can do other things so my
intuition here is that even if white for
example trades on d8 and plays Rook D1
black could end up in serious trouble
with the C4 Pawn for instance after the
trade let's make a random move boom
there you go you can't defend the pawn
anymore okay that's how quickly this
could actually all have happen now the
question then is well what happens if
white does the same thing after Queen A5
well if white plays Knight H4 here we
can now move the bishop
you can say well doesn't that give away
the E4 Pawn but that's the whole point I
think the best move here is to start
with Rook takes D1 now what is White
gonna take back with presumably the
bishop in order to keep A2 protected and
now we drop the bishop back to D7 I saw
this line when I was playing Queen A5
Bishop D7 why Bishop D7 in order to
prepare the move rookie 8 here skewering
the bishop on E1 which is now undefended
because the other Bishop has removed the
contact between white shark and the
bishop you see how everything is
interconnected this is what it all boils
down to these subtleties
and after Bishop D7 ironically we're
threatening to move G5 which would trap
the Knight on H4 that used to be
you know the papa in the whole operation
now what if white takes with the Rook on
D1 well probably that's how a grand
master would play but now we can drop
the bishop back to E6 and after Queen
takes E4 Queen takes A2
it's clear to me that black is not worse
according to the engine Queen B1 is
equal but I would still prefer black I
think our pieces are a little bit more
harmonious a little bit more active
so that is the logic behind Queen A5 the
queen is awkward yes but pieces can be
moved to better spots later and Knight
T4 was a big decision by our opponent I
would not have played that I would have
played Knight D2 with white I would have
played Knight C2 for sure and and tried
to surround the E4 pawn and after Rook
fe8 I don't know it's a complicated
position I think the position's about
equal the engine is giving some crazy
line Knight C4
now there's the Intermezzo Rook takes D1
um obviously the queen is Untouchable
because the Rook on A1 Falls and the
bishop Falls with check so it has to
take back
Queen takes A2
Knight D6 infiltrating
rookie seven very scary for black Bishop
C4 sacking another Pawn
Knight takes F7
wow and if Rook takes F7 the best move
for white is G4 now the bishop is
attacked and after Bishop C8 Queen F4
wins the game
look at this and The Rook on F7 is
suddenly Under Fire And if black defends
it with 95 in Comes The Rook to d8 and
everything collapses the bishop the
Knight Etc pretty disgusting attacking
play on all sides so after Knight takes
F7 black has to play the cold-blooded
Bishop E6 trade on E6
98 is the best move
Queen B3 counter-attacking The Rook Rook
D7
and this is all leading us to equality
bang bang bang
Rook D7 back
and uh rookie seven and we trade
and white takes and after King f8 you
get an obviously equal end game
very simple stockfish variation what am
I trying to show by showing you this
line I'm trying to show you how
complicated these positions are and the
fact that it's not like when a GM looks
at this position I see this line I
didn't see two moves of this line to be
honest with you I didn't even understand
that we can play Rook takes D1 I saw
Knight D2 and Knight C4 I thought that
we would have to drop our Queen back to
C7
I didn't see Rook T1
this is brazen I mean I would never go
for this if I'm black because it looks
absolutely terrifying I also would never
see the move G4 this is a completely
inhuman idea to force the bishop off of
F5 so that Queen F4 becomes possible
no I probably wouldn't find any of this
in a classical game either
but I could sense that if the Knight
gets to C4 there might be some trouble
for black because what I did see was the
D6 Square
and I did understand that if the Knight
reached D6 then there would be some
trouble for black instead our opponent
clarifies the situation with Knight D4
we took on D4 and played Queen B6
and now I want to explain why well let's
explain this through the lens of this
position
and by the way in this position I
actually think that White had to play D5
I think that this was White's last
chance to equalize I think White had to
play D5 uh but what would have happened
what would have actually happened if
white would have played uh G4 Bishop
takes C6 Queen take C4 so here I don't
think the black should do anything
drastic I think the black should just go
Rook after d8
and the D4 Pawn is actually going to be
lost on the next move white does not
have the Firepower to defend the pawn
and if white loses that pawn white
should be worse here because his King is
obviously inferior and if white tries to
to double on the D file and get the
Rooks off the board well obviously F2
Falls with check
so
I I G4 is not something that I would
even calculate because let's say that
you didn't see Rook FDA worst comes to
worse you play Bishop D5 you set the
bishop up with a beautiful blockading
Square how bad can this be you're only
down upon White's King is permanently
weak your pieces are excellently placed
and this is the point I want to make to
higher rated players who are watching
this you don't need to calculate
everything you need to use your
intuition not only to figure out what's
good and what's bad but also to figure
out what needs to be calculated and what
doesn't a line where you sacrifice a
pawn and clearly get great compensation
you don't need to sit there for five
minutes is this enough compensation or
not practically you know that it's good
practically you know that it's good how
do you know that it's good because you
know that the king is permanently weak
and you know that your pieces are better
placed that means I wouldn't calculate
here past Bishop D5 there is also the
move F5 etc etc
so I think Rook D2 is the beginning of
the end for white
I would have played the move D5 here and
forced pieces off the board this would
have led to a draw
this would have led to a draw trade on
E3 the best move here according to the
engine is Rook C7 it's actually not it's
actually not Bishop takes C3 because why
after BC white can connect the pawns
with C4 so even though this technically
makes more Pawn Islands the major Pawn
island is the one in the center and this
actually joins the pawns together does
that make sense so Rook C7 here is the
best move
white can play D6 but that actually
weakens the pawn
so it's better to play Rook ac1 and
protect the bishop black doubles white
pushes
Rook C5 and you just get a very
complicated end game very complicated
end game white is supposed to play
Bishop G4
and you get some sort of a uh
liquidation of the Bishops you play
Bishop takes G4 HG Bishop takes C3
uh Rook takes C3 Rook takes C3 BC and
you get apparently an equal end game an
equal end game white is gonna go Rook D4
black is going to go F6 King F7 King E6
you can take my word for it this is
equal
does that make sense
so
D5 here uh is a move that I would play
why would I play it what would be the
impetus for me uh if I were playing
white to play the move D5 well I would
sense that if blackened could complete
the doubling of the Rooks on d8 the D4
Pawn is going to become a long-term
weakness so you never know when the
opportunity train is going to roll
around again and so I would take the
opportunity to trade pieces before that
opportunity is taken away
so Rook D2 Rook T8 Rook T1 and now H5
and I actually think that white had a
second opportunity to push D5 this was
the second opportunity but again there
was something about this move that my
opponent didn't like
uh I don't know what it was but yet
again I think this end game is
approximately equal
yeah maybe we would have played H4 to
prevent G4
I maybe I would take black by by a
smidge but it should end in a draw I
don't want to analyze this end game I
think this is basically equal it's clear
that this is equal our opponent starts
to panic here Bishop C4
Bishop C4
and King H7 preparing Bishop H6 now I
have demonstrated this idea before in a
completely different context
this idea of H5 King H7 Bishop H6 is one
that occurs in a variety of different
positions I have two examples off the
top of my head both for my games
here's one here's one that I've shown
quite a bit
uh in in previous Speed Run games but
still repeating uh repeating uh
examples always a good idea
so in this position it is black to play
and I'll kind of introduce this to you
quickly because we are it is very late I
want to play bullet brawl tomorrow the
point is this
I want to seize control of the D4 Square
what's preventing me from doing that by
and large is the presence of this bishop
on E3 so I came up with the idea of
trading Bishops to trade Bishops I need
to get my Bishop to H6 and to do that
here's that idea again H5 King H7 and
Bishop H6 Boom the Bishops are off the
board and now I can very calmly get my
knight to D4 okay so that's example
number one example number two
and this is a bit of an incomplete idea
but you'll get the point here pretty
quickly
white to play in this position
white to play in this position what
would you do what would you do in this
complicated middle game how would you
continue
so I asked myself okay what pieces can I
improve here and of course the the piece
that's the most miserable is the bishop
on G2 because it's just staring at my
own Pawn I thought well okay I want to
improve that bishop and I also noticed
that the queen and the Rook were aligned
much like in the speedrun game and I
played the move King H2
and I Was preparing to play H4 and
Bishop H3 my opponent saw that idea and
he panicked he panicked sorry he
panicked with Queen B5 immediately
walking into a lovely tactic Bishop
takes D4
now if Ed then E5 opens up the bishop
so he played CD and now bang Rook takes
F7 classic tactical idea The Rook on C8
is unprotected
so that's the problem with Rook F7 my
opponent gave up a queen for two Rooks
but my queen infiltrated to G5 and
everything started to collapse here for
black I literally just took all of the
pawns I finally opened up my bishop and
I was able to check my my opponent of
course in the end my Bishop ironically
remained on G2 but what set all of this
in motion was this King h2h4 Bishop H3
idea okay that that's what caused my
opponent to panic much like I think it
did in the in our speedrun game people
don't like this idea
um so I think
here after King H7 Rook C2 was
a inaccuracy I don't think it was a huge
mistake just yet I think it leads to a
worse position I don't know exactly what
white should do here according to the
engine the only way to keep equality is
Queen to E1
Queen to E1 and the point is that after
Bishop takes D4
you play
gosh apparently you play the immediate
Bishop takes F7
what the heck
Bishop C3 BC
and again it's the same point the Rooks
are piled up on The d8 Rook so you can't
you can't take F7 It's actually an easy
tactic to understand once it's played
but try playing it right takes takes
takes takes takes takes and you get a
drawn end game
write a drawn end game
so apparently that was the way to draw
Queen E1 I mean why why Queen E1 you
know how do you find that very difficult
though very difficult move by the way if
you play D5 now
then already this end game is a much
inferior version of the the end game
that we were looking at why why is it
inferior who can explain conceptually
why is this a worse version for white
then for example the first instantiation
why is this position better for white
than the one that you're looking at
right now good little exercise in
perception
no the d-pawn was just as weak there
that's not the reason
it's not about the Rooks either the
Rooks are connected they're perfectly
fine it's about the placement of the
bishop on C4 that Bishop is in the way
of the C pawn and you can skewer it with
Rook C7
and after Rook D4 you can skewer it by
doubling your Rooks on the C file and
you pick up C3 and then E3 is likely to
fall as well
so these small details this is what the
game revolves around our opponent goes
Rook C2 Bishop takes D4
Bishop D4 Rook D4 and of course nearly
the decisive mistake Rook dc1
our opponent should have taken on D4 and
probably the best bet for black here is
to play Queen takes D4 and force the
queen trade that's probably
that probably is the best bet for
uh for for for black uh because if you
play Rook takes D4 I didn't see anything
in this position I I didn't see
uh a clear path forward I mean we can
give the check and we can give another
check but even if white plays Queen G3
the simplest move I don't see a clear
follow-up
so I actually think we should play Queen
takes D4 here and how does white proceed
well as I indicated this loses The Rook
to Queen D1 so that's a nice byproduct
and so we get by force this end game
this end game is better for black in
several different ways
um one way to play here
is to try to activate Black's King
through these dark squares and to get it
to F4
so the engine actually indicates the
move King to H6 and White's position is
quite difficult to play the reason why
largely is that the Rook is tied down to
the second rank if white tries to seek
activity with Rook C7 then we give a
check and we drop the Rook back to D2
very classic Motif hitting F2 hitting B2
and very clearly this position is very
bad for white because the e-pawn is so
far Advanced even this position is very
difficult to defend because of the epon
and because blackstroke is so active so
it should make sense to people that this
end game is very nasty it's very nasty
uh for for white to play an end game
like this with limited time on the clock
now does it make sense why the move E3
is not as strong as it may appear
why is the move E3 who can explain not
as strong as it may seem and at a high
depth the computer actually likes King
H6 a lot but why not E3 why is this move
not that strong and this is a great
exercise for newer players in
understanding what makes a move
dangerous and what makes a move
innocuous
because White's gonna go rookie too and
physically Force this Pawn off the board
and you might say what about another
check well what about it what about it
white ghost King H2 there's nothing
what about Bishop D3 no that just
blunders the pawn so you have to
liquidate and you've removed from the
board your biggest asset your Pawn on e4
which is lording over the position
you've given it away
okay so this is why you shouldn't just
automatically play these moves which
look tempting and flashy you need to
actually calculate that
in any case Rook takes D4 would have
given white excellent drawing chances
our opponent shies away from that and
after Rook D1 check I think that this is
almost the end white is a pawn down
white has no activity and no time on the
clock and our opponent defended very
valiantly Queen G3 we decided to keep
the Queens on the board I'm not gonna
delve too deeply into the alternative
option you can analyze this on your own
I'm sure that this end game is winning
with best play
instead we decided to keep the Queens on
the board now H4 now H4 hitting the
queen and trying to open up access for
our Queen to drop to E5 another very
important Point why are we even
positioning this Pawn in H4 well the
general idea is that when you get this
position without the pawn on H4 white
can block with the queen and white can
block with the pawn with impunity now
white can't block with a queen and if
white blocks with the pawn then
obviously you're also dealing with the
problem of H takes G3 so remember this
if you're looking and you're trying to
learn important tactical ideas when the
king is on H2 like this a Pawn on H4
goes a very very long way toward
ensuring that the king is essentially
boxed in
let me see if I can illustrate this with
a with an example with a famous example
once chess base unfreezes I'm going to
do that but for now let's continue the
game Queen C7 Rook D7 dropping The Rook
back to the seventh rank now securing
all of our pawns and centralizing our
Queen with Queen E5 check
G3 and Rook D3 just wins the game Rook
D3 wins the game
White had a final chance in this
position who can tell me what White's
final chance was I didn't see this
during the game I did not see this move
during the game after G3 Rook D3 the
game is over and I think I was able to
find an ultra precise sequence with E3
an ultra precise sequence but apparently
White had the move F4 now I thought this
was impossible because Ivan passant but
of course now we see that this gives up
the queen so F4 would have kept white in
the game
although we would have dropped our Queen
back to B8 and look at how weak this
Pawn is Rook D3 is a huge threat and I
think practically White's position is
nearly unplayable practically I think
white is nearly unplayable here
but that would have stayed in the game
now you might look at this and say for
the life of me I don't understand why
you didn't just take on H3
what's the reason the reason is that the
Rook on H3 is now very awkwardly placed
and White's Rook is about to infiltrate
to C7 and start picking off some of our
pawns is black winning absolutely but
this gets a little bit messy with the
Rook getting to C7 you see what I'm
saying so I was trying to find a way to
circumvent that and that's where the
move E3 came to mind I'm always looking
at contact between pieces I noticed that
the Rook is making contact with the
bishop and so I quickly was able to
understand that E3 threatens Rook takes
B3 that's a crucial element of this
sequence you have to see that otherwise
you won't understand you won't
appreciate the value of this move
the other thing to realize is that if
white goes rookie two you take on F2 and
compared to that other position the
white Rook is now Ultra passive the
white Rook is now Ultra passive so
you're not worried about the Rook
infiltration to C7 the
vegetable reason that you play E3 now
let me see if I can find the
illustrative game
it's alokine against Kali it's a pretty
famous game
oh yeah I mean it's a little bit it's a
little bit different
no it's not it's not the same thing
while since we're on the topic I might
as well show it to you
this is not it of course this is the
previous game yeah so basically this is
alakai Kali I misremembered this game I
thought that white had a Pawn on H5 here
but he didn't
does anybody know this combination what
did alakai do here to win the game and
by the way his previous setup of was
Bishop takes G6 he actually saw this
from the previous move
yeah so this is a deflection combination
you should pause on YouTube If you're
looking at this queen takes D7 yeah Rook
D7 and now you put both of your Rooks on
the eighth Rank and black loses because
the king actually has no Escape because
of the queen because of the queen
here Rook h8 is still made and the C1
square is protected by White's Rook
there is just no defense to Rook h8
anyways I remembered this because you
can see what the relation is right the
king is on H7 uh so that's how I kind of
uh that was the the mental reference
uh so cut just in general you know
combinations with the King on H2 like
this or on H7 are more common than you
might realize and after Bishop takes F7
the final nail in the coffin Rook D7
double attack on the bishop and The Rook
a lot of you guys were too eager to play
Rook D2 without realizing that in this
position white actually stops the pawn
with Bishop B3 and you don't have this
move that that square is controlled so
black has a lot of work to do in this
position still
so rather than automatically going Rook
D2 you should first search for a double
attack which exists and if white counter
attacks The Rook the easiest way to win
is just to take and because the
promotion square is a dark Square you
know that the pawn cannot be stopped
okay and the rest of the game was very
straightforward we just piled up on the
H3 Pawn
and then at the end we tied The Rook
down to E2 and we finally involved our
King and Chuck made it along the light
squares
wow that was quite a game and that was a
very detailed analysis I hope you
enjoyed
critical moments in this game
first of all uh Bishop D2 passive move
this gives us a very easy game
I think the decision to play Queen D5
was a pretty instructive one then we
decided to run our epon up the board in
a really really big moment was here when
white decided to force things with
Knight D4 this created an easily
attackable Target which we attacked we
compromised White's positioning of heavy
pieces we then switched targets to
Target the queen and the Rook that
caused Dwight to panic and give up a
pawn and rather than recapturing it
white panicked further then we were able
to convert our advantage by creating the
preconditions for an attack against
White's King and ultimately using those
preconditions to force a favorable end
game and then E3 was the nail in the
coffin
and that's how we won
uh this will be up on YouTube tomorrow
guys uh but for now it's time for me to
sleep I do have the bullet brawl in six
hours no at 1am uh 1 pm
but I do have something in six hours
from now so
um I'm going to head out this was a much
longer stream than anticipated
but I hope you enjoyed the speed run
foreign
[Music]